the year-long intermission finally over  for the las vegas philharmonic starting  october 8th performances are back the  orchestra will perform all nine of  beethoven symphonies and new music also  will be revealed there is also going to  be a holiday showcase that's in the  works the orc orchestra says since it's  been so long they are starving for this  community engagement  the community has really responded with  such excitement and enthusiasm for  coming back to the smith center  performing  and listening to live music again  and what a venue to see him there  tickets on sale now for the upcoming  concert series